-Welcome back, everybody.
We're hanging out
with Reese Witherspoon,
who stars in "Sing 2."
You're back as the voice
of Rosita.
-Yes.
-Is it fun to get
back with the cast?
I know you did a little press.
-Oh, my gosh.
It's been so much fun.
We went and they had
the premiere of the show
and it was all little kids
in a theater,
and they were all standing up
and singing all the songs.
And I've never been in
a movie where
I saw people stand up
and sing and cheer,
and it was just pure magic.
-Did you get nervous
that you had to
perform an Ariana Grande song?
-Yeah, I had to sing
Prince, Ariana Grande, U2.
I was so scared.
-You're like, "Oh, my God,
what is going on?"
-I was like, "This is
not gonna be good."
But it was really great.
Harvey Mason, he produced it,
and he's amazing.
I was like,
"Make me sound good."
-Yeah.
-"I got you."
-Have you met Ariana?
-Have I met her?
No, I've talked to her,
because she did
a "Legally Blonde" video.
She did an homage so Elle Woods,
which was so
sweet and thoughtful.
-She's one of the most fun --
You would totally
get on with her.
She's so great.
-I really like that, Jimmy.
Maybe you can, you know,
hook a friend up.
-Yeah, no problem.
I also have his number, as well.
-Okay.
-No, look,
he is not in this film,
but Matthew McConaughey is,
Scarlett Johansson.
And then the addition
to the cast is Bono.
I know.
-Come on.
-Bono, Pharrell, Halsey.
-Oh, yeah, I forgot.
-Halsey has
the most amazing number,
and then we all have --
there's like, seven
musical numbers at the end
where everybody's
dancing and singing
in these beautiful costumes,
and I'm telling you,
it was like,
everybody was singing.
It was so fun.
-Isn't it fun to
do a movie like that,
like a big, animated movie
that's just gorgeous
and everyone loves?
We all need it right now.
-It's such a dream.
-I want to show everyone
a clip.
Here's Reese Witherspoon
as Rosita in "Sing 2."
Take a look.
-Guys, come on!
Wait!
[ Tires squeal ]
♪♪
-Listen, you guys.
I have dreamt of performing
in Redshore City
since I was a little kid.
And besides,
I just convinced my husband
to babysit for the next
24 hours,
and I am not gonna waste
an opportunity like that.
So come on!
[ Bag thuds ]
We've got nothing to lose!
♪♪
-Aww.
-Come on.
You got nothing to lose!
It's hopeful!
Go check out this movie.
I loved it.
Reese Witherspoon, everybody!
"Sing 2" opens in theaters
December 22nd.